this video is brought to you by better
help as two people who have been in
therapy for many years now we are proud
to be partnered with these
guys citizens of the reject Nation it is
time to experience the magical Joy of
Wonka joined today by of course jonka
over here you excited I am in a world of
pure
anticipation yeah last month I did a
reaction to the original Jean Wilder
classic and I loved it and I am ready to
go in comparing every frame of this to
that OG film and I expect it to meet all
of my expectations now I'm sure this is
going to be a fun time guys what do you
think about this film does this live up
to the hype for you what's your favorite
song or musical number from here leave
it in the comments down below you know
what to do leave a like on this video
also slurp up that subscribe button
don't know why you chose that word
prepper thanks for helping us edit down
these highlights also big thank you to
all who making our patreon a great great
success over there you can get the full
length scratch and watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy of Wonka
of course available for super sexy
rejects but Wonka and I cover several
things over there exclusively with
highlights and watch sh Longs included
see ju WKA it took me a second while
it's subtle it's a sub subtle Ry anyway
guys let's see what all the hype's
[Music]
about there's nothing like the Gene
Wilder version it's okay the WB is
filled with chocolate though oo yummy
golden
rapper Ral doll story company Ral doll
Cinematic Universe is that what we got
on our I mean he's a prolific writer so
if you can get over some of his more
controversial
qualities darkest
Brazil
opening number opening numbers determine
the entire Vibe of your
movies after years
ofwell is this where you found Oompa
Loompas City I've pinned s years of
hopes on Lies Over the Horizon there's
no place like
London land
Theo all
right yeah that's cool look at these all
these sideway twisty
[Music]
angles
su he just seems so much cooler
now yeah get that smile going you're on
Broadway now
kid
[Music]
wow he was so friendly with
people a hat full of Dreams wow look how
beautiful that
is The Grand Budapest Hotel is just up
the mountain that's gray wire
workk that's a Harry Potter
map where they pumpkin spice everything
won are suspicious extreme my pumpkin
you pay for it I like your Wonka
chocolate I've got five six
seven got to be broke in no time Willie
no leave me
alone beat the
bo oh you see he was resistant towards
the child lorth he's being a slugworth
right now it's everything you said Mama
and
Mama we G to get his whole family
backstory we going to meet Mama
Wonka famous chocolate store just need
to unlock it will I crash and burn go up
like a rocket he just wanted a regular
store this looks like the atrium right
outside the Dolby
Theater of
dreams and a little auto
tune he was
insane he's a delusional man he was in
his own imagination taking I
wanka no
daydreaming what woe that's cute what a
strange
[Music]
rule a day you've been here for like a
couple hours man could you spare a
sovereign for a place to sleep love
of course you shot my shoes thank
[Music]
you
pocket it's the American dream right
here oh
no that's the American way and
a D I like his
voice
whoa what is his breath made of time for
a little night capap so he came back
with
a hat full of Tricks truly it's bigger
on the inside shoot go away stop go away
Sho Sho stop sit sorry about titles oh
seems to have an unusual interest in
your damn that voice those teeth you're
not planning on sleeping there are you
son oh it's just for a night by this
time tomorrow I plan to have made my
fortune whoa tomorrow you'll be frozen
solid oh don't be ridiculous it's like a
mysterious narrator this
guy Perhaps it is a little cold for
camping you got a csle now unfortunately
I'm not in a position to pay for a room
sir but as luck would have it I know
someone who might be able to help you
out far too trusting far too naive youry
BS off my front door you scrub it and
bleach I have something better than Jin
Mrs scrubb
it I guess some good raw doll flourishes
on this oh what didn't you
say is that on it is Olivia colan Olivia
colan warm your cockles by the fire gin
oh no no yes Mrs scrubb it put that book
down and get our guest a glass of gin
Poor Man's Frozen after death whoa I
mean he looks all right chin
chin
salute this extremely strong stuff yeah
you can run cars on
that Mr W car is temporarily embarrassed
temporarily embarrassed Story of My Life
tile your sex tape and first thing
tomorrow at the gallery Gourmet I plan
to unveil my most astonishing creation
yet prepare to be amazed as I present to
you whoa A tpot A Third Man Records
teapot that's for my stew that's for
Peter Rabbit it's in here somewhere
don't you worry Mr Wonker I can see
you're a man of great Ingenuity how
could you not be impressed with what you
just saw yeah now the room is One
Sovereign a night but you don't have to
pay till 600 tomorrow does that give you
enough time to earn a few pennies now
sign here and we're all done
excellent yeah don't read that fine
[Music]
print oh man pick up on Clues the girl
what girl that girl it sounded like read
the small print and they're wow that's
where he got it from
oh origin that's how we learned to trick
children
yeah yeah you don't want to listen to
Noodle Mr W cuz she's damaged orphan
syndrome orphan syndrome orphan syndrome
Oran syndrome orphan syndrome and I took
her in at the goodness of my art and
I've done my best Mr Wonka honest I am
distracting
him these are just your standard T's and
C's but you're welcome to take a look if
you want teas and SE I was
over break his kneecap kill him
yeah well B seems to be in order really
uhhuh
hello what how did you survive traveling
the seven wonders of the sea so is he
supposed to like grow into someone who's
jaded and destressing of people to the
point where he isolates himself at the
factory he's going to end the movie a
bitter man isolating himself from the
world I want to teach you a lesson you
miserable little bookm what did I do
wrong you know what you did you oh it is
a hard knock life for you again and
you'll be in this C all week do you
understand yes Mrs scrubb it sorry Mrs
scrubb it I should think
so I mean you got to teach orphans how
to get their attitude and check they
don't have a parent that's true got to
teach them that the world's a harsh
Place wow what vibrant
colors
as expected fickle
grber lovely typography wonder if we'll
see the mom the Tim buron went out of
the element of the dad now they're out
of the element of the mom you're really
weird my name is Willie won and I have
come to show you a marvelous morsel an
incredible edible
anible edible oh so quiet up and listen
down nope scratch that reverse it
a hover
Tru what magical
chocolate jungle mumbai's a little hly
wings flap
that's microscopic F like chocolate more
leaves and when nicely lay precisely one
little egg in each of the whoa that hat
must be so heavy Matt Lucas it beats its
wings with GL
and then as you will see theate will
Ando gracefully CGI Wonka yes every one
of those is on
[Music]
wire
won they for real
won You' never chocolate like this oh
wow
Miss bonon yes Mr slor call the
police a kagin
slugworth Mr slugworth Sir excuse me Mr
slugworth oh he's from ghosts and
Horrible Histories ever since I was a
little boy that is quite a handshake
it's a business handshake Mr woner lets
people know I mean business I mean it's
a hand squeeze is what you did and this
guy slugworth looks familiar too
[Laughter]
marshmallow that's right harvested from
the mow marshes of Peru wow I want to go
there salted with the Bittersweet tears
of Russian clown oh so all Russians yes
I've been in this business a very long
time that of all the chocolate I have
ever tasted this the absolute one 100%
worst no you knew was coming an
endorsement for Mr wait the worst we
three are the fiercest of
Rivals a good
chocolate plain uncomplicated they're
great color coordination on them cuz
he's black no ones were in yellow the
others are in blue the others were in
green anyway you're going to hate what
happens next fly fly oh oh that's the
hoverfly it's broken out of its cocoon
it's flapping its wings like billio burp
Charlie burp it'll be completely
unharmed thank in about 20 minutes It'll
get tired and exit through your rear you
what oh no why would you promote this
chocolate yeah who in their right mind
wants a chocolate that makes you fly
let's find out shall we who's for
hover I mean you just said it's going to
come out of your bum collect some some
money please please I'd be like once you
get this more fine tune for the after
effects I will gladly try your flying
chocolate nah he's got a market test
somewhere beat it beat it folks nothing
to see here I recognize that voice group
of people defying the laws of
gravity man afraid we've had some
complaints about you sir that you're
disrupting the trade of other businesses
I'm regretably obliged to move you on
and to confiscate your earnings no vend
what happened to good oldfashioned
capitalism could you at least leave me a
sovereign I need to pay for my room come
on man here one benevolent cop when I
commit The Purge of London I will not
forget you yeah I come through with my
chocolate
shotgun believe we said a sovereign for
the room yes but you have incurred a few
extras during the course of your
residency with ourselves
uh God there was that glass of gin you
had on arrival oh God if I remember
rightly you warmed your cockal by a fire
you get charged for that damn those
cockal oh then you've got your stair
charge that is p St pommer fried up and
down now tell me Mr Wonka what did you
happen to use the mini
bar mini bar of soap by a sink I might
have
briefly St bleacher no you never touched
a mini bar and he was raised in a
ditch and your pillow penalty and you
were looking at pillow penalty 10 ,000
sovereigns should have read the fine
print I don't have 10,000 sovereigns
you're going to have to work it off in
the washer a't you a sovereign a die
10,000 days is a Tool
album wow the instrumental music that
accompanies these scenes is a bit like
sensory overloading sure it is very
bouncy
very feels like it's trying to be on
stage Abus crunch chared accountant I
was now he runs the place and you best
do as he says well you're answer to me
Piper B oh she's from insecure Miss lty
Bell she don't talk much and I'm Larry
it is watertight but is it chocolate
tight they'll bring you right back and
she'll charge you a th000 for the
inconvenience yeah back to work come
along Mr Wonka don't worry you guys are
going to make a great Ensemble you can
make a fun song out of the factory work
first you Pi up the apparel and you it
in Barrel scrub scrub scrub scrub get to
work Wonka take to the mangle and giant
hand scrub scrub scrub scrub it's
[Music]
on the mangle and the
wreck halfen are you singing this
song yeah they're the Proto
oompas there's a lot of Reliance on
these like sway Dutch ankles to emulate
weirdness yeah Whimsy it's called Whimsy
scrub
scrub Wonka's like I hate this slave
labor I wish I could get little people
to do
this can't I P this off on
somebody it's a Nifty vest though like
this
vest oh that's a cool cool overhead shot
right there damn yeah told you to read
the small print slight problem with that
can't read you can't read can you I
focus my studies almost exclusively on
chocolate how do you know ingredients
and all
that everything else I've relied on the
kindness of strangers and look for
that's got you you've got a
bed oh if you can call it that the water
comes in two temperatures cold and
colder it's actually really well well
done edit so you can see the
colder how much do you owe them 10,000 I
owe 30 how do you owe the money I
thought they found you down the laundry
Sho charged me out black tax took me in
out of the goodness of their hearts and
charge me for the privilege the greedy
beat the needy every time Mr Wonka those
horn swaglers and snos wangers that's
just your orphan syndrome talking oh my
god wow dude I'm making chocolate of
course how do you like it dark white
nutty absolutely insane dark never had
any you would
never
lucky for you noodle I have a selection
of the world's finest ingredients right
here in my travel
Factory that is quite a travel factor
that is a super travel Factor Silver
Linings made of cond
thunderclouds and liquid sunlight holy
[__] the magic tricks are through the
roof back when I was your age I wanted
to be a
magician my mom was a cook how long ago
was that just the two of us in a perfect
little world tomorrow a there's no
earthly way of knowing which direction
they are going spend every waking hour
trying to come up with some new trick to
my Mom hey what's Su Sally Hawkins that
is a really cool way to do a flashback
but the real magic came from her each
week she brought home one cocoa bean by
the time my birthday came around there
was enough to make a single bar of
chocolate hey this has to be the best
chocolate in the world they say the very
best comes from a place called the
Gallery G me right we'll see about that
it's impossible as it all happens you
know a little secret that even those
fancy pants don't what is it I tell you
when you're older you get to sleep how
did he wind up with an American accent
yeah to the calerie cormet the start a
shop yeah with our name above the door
and everything that's wonderful dreamone
is that all it is just a dream nice
little frame with the moon and the
clouds
every good thing in this world started
with a dream like
slavery man's dream
baby what was the
secret I never found out I was abducted
by yandu when I picked you up as a kid I
saved your life soon after she fell sick
before I knew it all I had left was her
bar of chocolate a that's really sad and
and her calligraphy that's why I'm here
noodle so I can feel the same way I did
back then and also start a cartoon band
Capture that childhood magic my mom
wants promise though when I share
chocolate with the world she'd be right
there beside me I know it sounds crazy
but I always hope she'd somehow keep
that promise that I could reanimate her
I captured a piece of her soul and I'm
going to infuse a chocolate bar
with all the sets and props are so
detailed and intricate it it's very they
really
populate world of Pure Imagination I
hear the tune you don't like it no I
like it it's just hope you don't want to
feel the hope I don't want to eat
anything else ever again now which day I
don't have chocolate well be a little
harder then how would you like to have
all the chocolate you can eat every day
have you heard of type two
diabetes what would I have to do just
get me out of here are you crazy I'll
get someone to cover my shift and you
can smuggle me out in your laundry car
keeps her a Beady eye on everything that
comes in and out of the was shelves
except drop a clue oh oh what do we got
huh what is it no it's nothing bribe her
with more Double H that's not nothing so
the one time she dropped a guard was
when this Aristocrat came to the laundry
all we have to do is find an aristocrat
and slip out while she's distracted
where are we going to find an aristocrat
yeah where we going to find some rich
[__] huh
huh
a double huh a good look the pencil and
paper uhhuh I got an idea that was anaha
currently just current at this moment in
time just let you guys know my thoughts
I like Timothy Shalom when he's going
bigger though I really feel like he's
acting he's reaching for the the height
yeah and I kind of feel that way about
the movie as a whole already sure that
like sometimes they're playing weird
instead of it just naturally being weird
sometimes it feels like they're I could
feel the attempt more than the genuine
aspect but sometimes it really works
we'll see we're still early it's my last
confession
oh R Aon hey temptation is very hard to
resist yes it is Mr cocoa bean send me
down what see you later you going to get
smited right now corruption at the
church there's a whole world here thank
you very much it's where they keep the
Union Wafers I brought my invoice one
choler moved on for the usual
fee it's like Kingsmen we think that Mr
woner might require a little more than
simply moving on oh and what's more he
only charges a sovereign of chocolate so
anyone can afford them even the the poor
the
poor oh dear I've just been a little bit
sick in my mouth oh heavens refrain from
mentioning that de demographic in my
presence
demographic Jesus Christ oh no we want
you to send Wonka a message that if he
attempts to sell chocolate in this town
again he's liable to meet with a little
accident in which he
dies that was so
funny really
funny I'm an officer of the law I can't
just go around roughing up your
competition well you can just got to
find a good
excuse oh I can see that you're a man of
integrity oh yes I like when musicals
use props around them to create
instruments diagetic
sounds I
do we've
[Music]
everything with the rich aund of your
favorites sorry I'm afraid it's no my
man with the
Integrity little sweet
to his sink could be better this is like
the dark side that prays on the
childhood desires yeah 700
boxes whoa
now boxes
chocolate boxes with the chocolate stock
in it in my pockets
fellas they're like bogas buns and Bean
or
something the farmers from Fantastic Mr
Fox oh no he's ging
in the
confetti body shaming what a tayor can
conceal
curdles keep your wretched chocolates 1
18800 boxes oh deal this is one long
haggle I really like that number a
lot toilet blocked again unmistakable
Sound Of Love don't tell me you had
noticed what she's madly in love with
you oh that's clever Ploy fine figure of
a man just need to tidy yourself up a
little bit have a bath a bath what's a
bath she'll be thankful for an angle
yeah
and please see your knees but if you
want to make her sigh tell me show her
some thigh oo yeah buddy that's some
foul language PG hike up your skirt a
little more Mr bleacher Jack bleacher I
like when shame gives a hint to that
Darkness the orary side of Wonka I was
collecting laundry from Professor
monacle the other day he's got sketches
of no woman all over his wall so and
this one looked rather familiar blow me
that looks exactly like Mr
bleacher I totally didn't clock it in
the moment but they're they're like the
twits it's another raw dollism which if
you're not familiar go check that one
out that book is
wild you guys that her all the time you
can't come up with a new song yeah come
on oh get it get it
[Music]
boy
change they acknowledged
it
wow them leader hosing have you done
something with your air maybe maybe
not oh yeah buddy where'd you get them
done g
l why did I Sho
me Mrs
Robinson oh she likey Oh I thought you
come over here and have a glass of Je oh
my God don't you come over here where
it's all hot oh yeah
buddy Wonka picked up on something
genuine I thought he was just tricking
this guy to do something stupid and
foolish that's the chocolate it's a
little bit sweet it's a little bit sour
or bitter let me ask you a question how
does titles want to spend all his time
chasing after
M with Willy Walker's wild and wonderful
wishy-washy WKA
Walker the run and I can have fun scrub
scrub Willy Wonka's wild wishy-washy
Wonka washer this Wonka's been growing
on me quite a bit
actually I feel like the pieces are
starting to co us a little
stronger we saw this and we're going to
be so his hat is like the Fantastic
Beast box yeah it's like a nud suitcase
they've been stol who bu the little
orange man Donald Trump he's my Nemesis
about Yi oh comes in the dead of the
night and he steals all my chocolate
been happening every few weeks for the
past three four years now really you
can't you don't seriously expect me to
believe this do you what other
explanation is there that's you go to
sleep Dream by Little Green Man orange
man green
hair stuff your face with chocolate
stuff
my that makes a lot more
sense the way these two play off each
other is really really strong but we can
make more chocolate only problem is I'm
All Out of Milk well that's not a
problem here hey I've got a bunch of
milk right here a that is stealing and C
Willy Wonka does not use any old cow's
milk oh of course I require the milk of
a giraffe going to the zoo there's one
at the zoo hey
Binga
Binga that's a bingo they're not going
just walk in there and milk it why have
you tried the little orange man didn't
didn't find
this my man it's cute how
willly Wonka like he's a uh like he's a
con artist Hustler but he's not
everything he's saying is genuine but he
seems like he's like a manipulator
there's only one chocolate he's a born
marketer well thank you very much God
they got another cast member from the
from the British ghosts Paul King do
that show too it's called a big night
out a single chocolate that perfectly
mimics a night on the town classic shut
that's the next is white
wine followed by Red a fun
seppies you're talking it's when he hits
the layer of whiskey fudge he'll get
emotion
I yes yes sir that is a horrible history
for
you I should have just kept my thoughts
to myself this movie is grow on me so
fast I love you so much What bond we sat
together in chemistry at school no no
don't hang up no Basel some old pork
from the back of the
cupboard it's like like once the medley
of high Jinx really takes off is is sort
of when it starts to find its Groove I
think why don't they fly away I don't
know perhaps they haven't thought of it
you're kidding they need someone to show
them the way that'll be you William it's
like a fun little Adventure through old
London giraff
yeah oh got to learn to read boy you've
got told them how to read why you're
nearly even by a tiger nearly is the key
word there noodle I've nearly been bu a
lot of things and none of them got more
than a
nibble he's got a little bit of the
Johnny Depp in there oh for sure I feel
like I see that more directly than wild
yeah for
sure let's get milking is that a real
giraffe good evening I don't think so
this isn't The Last of Us
okay or wonk synth or
whatever
you want to give it a go
noodle oh he Mak a
face yes I think she likes you I just
realized it's Willy Wonka's first orphan
child friend do you think you could
possibly spare a pine or two of your
milk the
hell that is a handy scarecrow where'd
you get that name
anyway it's all I have for my real
parents and for noodle or Nora or Nina
or nothing at all oh no when I was a kid
I always hoped that I'd find my parents
classic
drawings beautiful old building full of
books my mom she'd be waiting there for
me at the door that is a world of Pure
Imagination then I realized it was just
a stupid Dream It's a Lovely dream I'm
not going to let you rot in that Wash
House forever yeah buy you a guitar I
pinky promise and that's the most Solem
now there is sure aside from a legally
binding
contract
[Music]
seem
a Cheer Up
Charlie he's got an infectious optimism
more it's like a doctor who approaches
Wonka kind of yeah this is his companion
yes W would be a perfect just a
chocolate obsessed version of the
[Music]
doctor oh that's
better there you
[Music]
go there you
goood I'll allow it moodle's a good
one
I hate Zeus a grab them
[Music]
balloons Jesus won that's
magical
a holy
cow a that's
fun ah that is very inventive yeah Chief
you know that fell you wanted to word
with give me a sniper this is between me
and Mr Wonka out don't worry about me
I've talked my way to tighter spots than
this climbing my hat if this is about
Abigail I got a message for you pal whoa
damn oh my God broke his broke the ice
of his face chocolate in this town
you got it not really I'm
afraid I said say it five more
times what is this is dark yeah I have
water in my ear okay that makes
sense listen I'm
sorry
what sell chocolate in this town again
you're going to get more than a bonk on
the head I don't have a bonk on the head
can you give me just a second
sure oh god
wow police brutality at its finest
that's right where have you been and why
do you smell a giraffe oh how do you
know what giraffe smells like you don't
know what a giraffe I I'm deprived I'm a
chocolate maker not just any chocolate
the best in the world yeah well noodle
flattering me but she's
right plan is to sell chocolate and pay
off Mr scrubb it at least that was the
plan until let me guess you had a little
run in with the chief of police how do
you know that because I was slugworths
accountant
ah his regular Booker was off gai was
called halfway across the country to
take his place nice the light leaks
there were two sets of books one for the
authorities and one which told the truth
damn fickle grber and prodos have been
in cahoots for years
a sort of chocolate
cartel choc Illuminati storing the
excess in a secret vault deep beneath
the cathedral guarded Round the Clock by
a corrupt cleric and 500 coholic monks
the night's chocolate bar so silly I
love it chocolate bar there's thousands
of gallons of chocolate down there and
the cartel use it to bribe blackmail and
bludgeon the competition oh my God it's
like the main currency here there is
there a chocolate River in there I'll be
keeping The Ledger in the vault very
good sir oh and Mr
crunch ah crunch numbers you're fired
damn but they've got you right where
they want you you can't get a shop
without selling chocolate and you can't
sell chocolate without a shop how many
audio books does this guy do why do you
want to sell specifically here well I
guess cuz the the cafe Gourmet or
whatever it is for the mom yeah it's
where the best chocolateers are I don't
know how we're going to sell any
chocolate every time the police show up
you'd have to vanish in the thin air
like a magician right yeah but it's one
thing when you're on stage uh ropes and
pulleys and trap doors there's none of
those on the street what you have real
magic there are trap doors all over the
city they're called storm drains I'd be
happy to show you around if you cut me
in on the action yeah and if you need
someone to handle Communications I'm
your woman I did not know she could be I
actually used to work at the telephone
exchange I just got real tired of
talking but if Mrs scrubb catches you
trying to escape you'll all get 6 months
in the coupe so just think about that
before getting involved in this
hairbrain scheme but it's not
hairbrained Abacus Abacus crunch what a
good name I don't care how good his
chocolates
are when do we start
yes Willie Wonka must have cut all these
people out of profits yeah must have
pulled some Ray Croc
Mark Zuckerberg type [__] yeah it's a
monopoly a chopo you're a lovely man but
I'm looking for someone to sweep me off
my feet you know whisk me off to a life
of adventure could that be you oh snap
no everyone from ghosts is inic act of
self-confidence I I'd best be
taxi oh coming to get you Barbara you
have anything for a broken heart so the
tax never stop the girls think you're a
flop conf
it's true
atraight
orom oh wow this is an accurate
assessment yeah I'm a brown
person tall yes
chocolate cholate let's get some taps
going get yourself some WKA
Chocolate Kiss
yes I'm going just give the chocolate to
the chief of
police they'll come on board your side
yeah start an
uprising in the
streets have you tried his new one no oh
you've got to have a go just pop one in
and everything becomes a Broadway show
is
makes make you laugh all you say and do
all day will
be I want one give me
one most classical song and
dance hair
repair yeah throw the her noodle on
guitar that's a different
cat damn make sure that all
fris have
youate like oh look
[Music]
out my
man the flamingos he showed them the way
but You' never sold chocolate like
this W nice only one could drive the
whole right through a prop but what I'm
trying to tell you is if we don't get on
top of this we'll go bust chocolate
apocalypse chocolate
apocalypse you should just getting
business with Wonka yeah
[Music]
guys nice Tire Round that was very
sweet
wow what an aerial
[Music]
shot where is he where did he go he went
back to Diagon Alley oh my God snap dude
oh no no
no oh so that's how you're doing it it's
like Dr D little or The Nutty Professor
whichever one where Eddie Murphy's
fat start giving them human growth hor
[Music]
hormones a little boxing
glove it's a Ru wber machine so you're
the funny little man who's been
following me I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Luma an Ooma what now I will thank
you to stop gping at me as though I was
something unpleasant you'd found in your
handkerchief I find it uncomfortable and
frankly rude sure have absolutely no
right to go around EMB bottling innocent
strangers EMB bottling you've been
stealing from me for years you stole our
cocoa beans oh really do you mean that
you don't even remember remember what I
don't even know who you are no I don't
remember that allow me to refresh your
memory in the form of a song Oh I don't
think oh yeah
we hi got to T something for
you hey whoa thank you for
[Music]
that oh my
god oh
buddy dress like a circus tent being
fumigated for pests right
now oh poor
guy if you really think that's a
reasonable penalty for taking three
beans four four beans then I'm sure we
can come to some sort of understanding
but I can't give you my entire Supply
it's a trouble with industry you let me
out of here and we can discuss it like a
gentlemen we can come to some kind of
financial
Arrangement thank you now would you be
so very kind as to pass me that um
miniature frying
pan thank you thank you I say that is
quite a beast isn't it now come a little
closer yes here we go there we are
[Music]
what even though you know it's coming
they they sold the hit OA lumpas do not
negotiate good day sir OA lumpas do not
negotiate with terrorists he won hit me
on the head with a frying pan and jumped
out of the window of course he
did you don't believe me do you honestly
no I'm going to bring many of them over
here no definitely not but as it so
happens we don't need to sell chocolate
today you know that shop the one you've
been dreaming of we're signing a lease
may need a little
work wow the Bas start of a laundry
called scrub it and bleacher scrub it oh
you know it yes as a matter of fact I do
I'm happy to do whatever you guys want
you want them all to have little axent
in which they die not a
problem oh is it you
want Oh Mr
slug just a minute s slugworth the bad
guy in the first one I think the guy
who's like trying to lure Charlie is
posing as a slugworth or something you
have a guess a Mr honka he's been
sneaking out to sell chocolate with the
help of your serving girl little Bret
that hair do too I wondered if you might
help me put an end to their business hey
Wonka helped them find love
ladies and gentlemen greetings to you
all and welcome to wonk we are tonight's
[Music]
entertainment
wowe
wow now you can actually build this
place
heyy
yes
everybody wow wow you have a fast chance
build this place damn you built Splash
Mountain
your a world of your
own here is the child that you left
behind here is the kid with the c
go Queen
miror are you selling the chocolate or
people just eating it this is just like
an experience people come into and take
pictures at maybe it's like se's candy
where you get a free
sample just keep your
umbrella
handy do they ran I was going to say
they rain little C hard
candies now if you could make the ticker
tape and the confetti like edible
ribbon Easter
[Music]
Bunny ah the edible teacups nice I would
just walk in there and open my
[Music]
mouth how would you like your change
spendable or edible oh edible
please that's handy heart disease went
up in
London dental bills 50%
everything Mr Wonka yes what's going on
here Yeti sweat most powerful hair
potion in the world oh no nobody eat the
flowers what's wrong with them uhoh I'm
terribly sorry everyone and I know how
to explain this but it appears that the
chocolates have been poisoned oh no dude
oh my God I want my money back I want
compensation I want
revenge yep you got to do a factory
recall
manach my Jesus Christ get her a
razor and that I believe is the end of
Hon's chocolate
where did you get Yeti sweat God that
eye poop of that I mean that Vault
probably has just a whole bunch of other
magical things if they got access to all
this magic why did why aren't they as
good as he because you wouldn't put the
yeti sweat in chocolate that's true
that's
fair it must smell so conflicting in
there like a burnt
s'more isn't it obvious which are pretty
good chocolate cartel and the Mexican
cartel work
together Cesar chav or no El Chapo is in
on this Cesar chavas is
activist she promised she would be here
she wasn't you didn't actually think
that no I did if only you could read
please don't ever come on Noodle No I
think Mr Wonka needs to be alone see the
original story you get to know Mr Wonka
but this story you know Willie oh how
Willie became Wonka
and when you do share chocolate with the
world I'll be right there beside you
looks like the tree from Sleepy Hollow
now terrible shame what happened yet so
he hears his mom's voice like Rebecca
Ferguson paired up with a black girl I'm
seeing some WB typ casting for Timothy
sham oh uh oh so why have you come to
gloat no Mr woner I don't waste my time
with that sort of thing this is the
precise amount you owe Mrs scrub it this
is for the number cruncher the plumber
oh can buy them all out
diaba is for the girl now we put in a
bit extra for her so that she can get a
place to live clothes toys buy a dad yes
you could change her life know what I
have to do leave town ow them never make
chocolate again waa man time to smother
that little girl with a
pillow for real dark chocolate in this
[Music]
movie One Day checking out always
yeah I
just I hope they all reject the
money go find your Loompa buddy and get
him to help you out your ticket uh one
way they going to fix you with some
chalk cre shoes and send you to sleep
with the fishes Mr
Wonka
oh no shaking
whatsoever what do we got oh what we got
a secret plan for the chief of police
who's a chocolate ad you'd think you'd
want the best chocolate here I
know
I've been doing my songs one more jar
and we're even or if you prefer I will
accept half a jar of those rather using
HS I don't make chocolate anymore oh
dear please don't tell me you're going
to go through with this ridiculous deal
I have to for noodle I promised her a
better life oh if you are determined to
just sit there feeling sorry for
yourself I am going flat like so is like
simultaneously a good effect and an
upsetting effect
I
know he's going to give us a double huh
oh no nothing well it's obviously
something because you said huh I'm sorry
forget it very
well
huh tell me what it is or I shall poke
you quite viciously with a cocktail
stick where stugor shook my hand his
ring left a mark see it's an a
surrounded by S's so what ass probably a
family ring yes but noodle has one just
like it
ohang why would noodle the orphan have a
slugworth family ring there's only one
reason I can think of and if I'm correct
noodle could be in grave danger well
come on Wonka spit it out produce your
Al pellet of wisdom oh my God what a
reference Wonka I demand an you could
explain on the way back
captain Oh my God the explanation can
wait
yes hope you brought enough for
everyone
wo well gentlemen one dead chocolate
here has requested that's
Grim oh my
God your friend Mr Wonka done a deal
with Mr slugworth gave up on his dream
to settle your account wowe SC Bookworm
fail sling your
friends wow you got to tell me twice
you've been a terrible audience good
night keep going you've got
something thanks for the encouragement
man biggest part of the lot but this
isn't to pay your bill this is to keep
you here what Mr slugworth doesn't think
nasty little urchins like you should be
out on the streets lowering the toone oh
my god wow lowering the tone you don't
still think he's a lord do you we made
it up you stupid Old Tag
ouch oh but they can break her out from
here or make some chicken related
chocolate hey I thought you'd gone I did
slugworth promised you a better life but
he didn't exactly keep nice so I came
back hey
nood nice catch so everyone's good at
catch and throwing in this y everyone
playing catch with dad growing up in
this movie you said the cartel keep a
record of all their Dirty deeds in the
green Ledger yes we get hold of that we
can prove that they poison our chocolate
scrub it and bleacher would go to jail
and we'll all be free Lord about
slugworth how an ingenious orphan an
accountant a plumber a telephone
exchange operator and a man who can
speak underwater combine those talents
and pull off the heist of the century I
was thinking this was a heist movie when
they were first trying to get out of
their room could you spare a piece of
chocolate for a star of an orphan I'm
sorry my child I don't have any on me oh
we accept venmo and cash out
sh
yes get this C fired
man everything all right back there
everything's fine isn't it Abigail hey
even Abigail's On The Crew it's Baron
Fon schmeichel Hammer's funeral today
and his widow Baron fichel Hammer a bit
of a Pious type so I don't want to see
anyone eating chocolate during the
[Music]
service nice
giraffe
run oh save
yourself judgment has pass oh we've
entered a song they're sing chanting in
the most
unexpected run
away they just all speak and chant you
know what you've done Julius you've sold
your soul for 30 pieces of chocolate
it's like the Continental Hello Operator
how am I direct your cor I need the zoo
putting through to the escaped animal
department now oh hello Zoo oh yeah I
think you did lose a
giraffe
oh forgive me oh of course a
weak you remember forgot that the
giraffe had a taste for
Acacia oh no so sorry for your
loss we're just having a few technical
difficulties technical diffic are you
the cleric who called about a
giraffe oh oh we're breaking in got to
get into the
Vault Wonka's 11 this is where you got
the idea for an elevator yeah but can we
make it out of glass does it come in
glass does it come in
GL thanks for all your hard work father
Julius and the chocolate
cartel a sweet how do dancing and then
when does the emotions come she can
really
move Happ P away oh no I can't I will
give him c yeah I like that for
you oh that's clever man that's clever B
is gwenny those days in chemistry class
the happiest of my
life no okay as long as they both pass
out sorry about this sir the seafood
truck spilled its load there's so many
blasted flamingos about these
days the Town Square was closed this
morning after a bizarre incident at the
city Cathedral delaying the funeral of
noted philanthropist now it's a spy
movie amen
amen he's got a phone right there we saw
him use it earlier it's funnier now
what's your what's your memory on this J
well wasn't a service
happening geography I get it now oh we
had a giraffe in here earlier had to
clear the whole place for about 20
minutes but everything's back to
normal hello Donovan FL it yes oh
Donovan it's not in here Willie Abus
said that it was here Abus has been in
the wash out for the past 4 years maybe
all the scrubbing has gone to his head
scrubbed his memory all that's down here
is just a bunch of stupid old
chocolate what are the odds great trope
LLY look the green book better use an
oven mint cuz that's a cooked
book ooh not not a chocolate gun
yes with candy bullets yeah but she's
not just an urchin is she Mr slugworth
oh your family they're draped against
the blue which is a more trusting color
there it go the green of greed yes Mr
slugworth has when just like it don't
you Mr slugworth as a matter of fact I
do that belonged to my brother Zeb EAD
fell in love with a common little book
one died before they could marry no
wonder she reads leaving me sole heir to
the family fortune or so I thought not
sole Heir though but 9 months later your
mother turned up on my door snap begging
me to get a doctor for her sick little
newborn you're a little baby I said I
would help just took the kid instead you
put me down a laundry shoe scrub it
found me she saw The Ring thought it
wasn't in and called me noodle but it
wasn't it was Z for Ze smart nice it was
right there the whole time
Zed my mom what was her name no I don't
think I could remember that but you have
to understand she was a woman poor and
poor Dorothy Smith says so right here
here well what do you know I guess you
did teach me to read after all it's in
financial I didn't even notice he was
reading yeah me too how much chocolate
do you have your factory Mr fickle grber
yeah about 80,000
gallons 75 I've got 150 damn going to
drown you in chocolate death by
chocolate you knew this was coming Pete
then what you're going to serve it to
the people yes it better be a chocolate
tidal wave Flo going through the streets
by the end of
this uh gentlemen considering the
situation I wondered if you do a good
deed on my behalf
oh a sort of pointless act of
selflessness yes of
course would you like us to do thank
you actor I was wondering if you could
give this to someone little orange man I
owe a jar of chocolates you see well I
think these might be the best I ever
made but in that case I'll make sure he
gets them personally I wonder if he did
describe them in the book as being like
8 in tall or less than a foot then why
don't they get an 8 in tall actor yeah
you know they're plenty of 8 in tall
people out there who would be hungry for
a rooll like
this damn
wow yeah this movie does not sell me on
chocolate no what are we going to do
Willie I don't know noodle eat all the
chocolate yeah we got to drink our way
out I wonder they had to have some
practical pools I wonder what they
filled them
with swanka whiel scrumptious orgasm
Delight we're not going to drown willly
look there's a light we'll let the
chocolate Lift us up we'll bang on the
glass somebody hears us Shut Up N yes
gentlemen it was a bit of a close shave
this morning and I was wondering if
perhaps we could rethink our Arrangement
oh
Christ
oh just leave things as they
are but do you think we should have
saved some for the little orange man
tell me your joke leave the joke making
to the professionals all right prod
knows oh that looks like very
uncomfortable things they P them put
them in oh my God how L did it take for
them to shower that off you found my
family a mom who loves loved me that's
all I ever
wanted it's just a bit of
chocolate correction it was actually my
chocolate yep you got some confessions
of your own to make Padre whoa you have
made a very grave error gentlemen you
steal from anaa we take back a
thousandfold you fell asleep on the job
yeah all right seriously you're like a
super spy man
it's draining
noodle we've been
saved by who there's so much chocolate
in my lungs the little orange man look
the little orange man you flew back up
there thank you thank you orange man
orange man it's funny like the OA looma
given a personality and what's that
personality hug Grant it is hug Grant oh
my god dude love progressively getting
fatter throughout this movie jeez you're
going to need like a chariot from now
on okay going to get you a Col I'm sure
car
shrunk a couple of Thieves broke in but
I'm afraid they met with a little
accident crap their pants they died
oh I wouldn't be so sure about that
officer would you kindly take a look at
this Wonka it details every single
illegal payment these men have ever made
thousands of them we made sure to write
it all down that sounds like a case for
the chief of police do you give it to me
aable I'll uh I'll take it off your
hands you know save you the paper can't
do that I'm afraid sir yeah aable you're
in this book because your name is
written down here huh a lot that's
impossible show me the evidence been
paying for that chocolate all by myself
oh my policeman's humble salary why are
we have you didn't eat any of those
chocolates did you Mr slug because
they're hover Chuck Delayed Action but
extra strong oh like extended release
ater Ral yeah look at the best lawyers
Pride the judge rig the jury if they
have to we'll be fine not a good luck
doing
blackface even if it's
delicious ladies and gentlemen I am a
chocolate
Batman I drink your chocolate
fault what is that it's our chocolate
that is not look a appez don't worry
gentlemen you'll come down eventually
they no they're going to fly up into the
atmosphere and burn
up a
buddy
Winnie go to
him oh my God God just put strawberries
there yeah that F fondue fountain
life damn Willie you clean up
good God I want a cup of just molten
Harry Potter L yeah it does I mean you
can easily fit
this yeah you can definitely convert
it original bar it's got to be all
oxidized by
[Music]
now the where you got the C
ticket it's the love it's the
marketing it's the people you share it
with a mama but I only have so much
chocolate yeah and I hate
people well there she
is a
mama a should have been a chocolate
kiss I saw her noodle she was right
[Music]
here thank you oh are you going to get
to try
[Music]
any yeah double huh is it as good as you
remember every little bit wish you could
last forever you'll figure that out I
need to go steal some oal loas yeah guys
are really resourceful is he turned the
cathedral into a factory do you know how
many people in the city are named D
Smith she spent the entire afternoon
ringing around we found her she's still
alive MMA she works in the library
that's where she lives hey of course
lives at the library she like the quasim
Moto of the library I hope they perform
like a labotomy on her she's like
brained in
come with me
oh and what else what we see
you will be be be what tell
[Music]
what that's
awesome
out
what just in your
imagin have you not heard any of the
chocolate commotion going on
[Laughter]
[Music]
outside need
explan
oh that's cool I like this plot line a
lot yeah I was wondering if I'd see you
again I'm not going anywhere Willy Wonka
not until you've paid your debt until
such time as the chocolate is physically
in my
hat l more than a shop I'm sure you will
I'm going to need a factory good luck
with that and someone to head up the
tasting Department come
with oh my God pick up the tempo fun
version woohoo frankly I rather doubt it
begin with a spin oh nice holy [__] like
a time lapse if you want view Paradise
wowe any
you want do it oh my
God CH is going to grow blonde hair and
blue eyes
yes she building it right now get them
Gob
Stoppers he did it well done began a
franchise started open factories up all
over the
world oh
myON oh
yeah yes
[Music]
sirry no way his ex saw the ACT laughed
a lot and took him back that's sweet
what is wrong with this thing infernal
machine come on man shows faft nose job
OB whoa big old ass in the country
La yep we ain't done nothing oh except
poison all them chocolates oh my God the
evidence drink the evidence just a
second officer police open up one I'm
done
uh yes we help you officer you two are
coming with me it's like bad Hulk and
Gora yep nebula
cosplay ah you're made for each other
you deserve each
other don't read the
credits be distracted
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video I've literally just finished
a therapy session and I wanted to shoot
this cuz I'm in this state of knowing
why I Champion mental health support so
much in the past few weeks work's been a
little bit hectic it's led me to miss
some sessions and I really don't like
doing that and sometimes that's when the
weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot
of I can't sleep even though I'm so
tired sometimes just a very deep-seated
sense of Gloom meditating and sometimes
journaling are my daily go-tos but
sometimes they just don't cut it when
I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down and
really especially after a session like
today therapy just really helps clear
the fog discussing the feelings is a
critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
bipolar and PTSD it's truly a
Cornerstone of my well-being and I'm not
alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own
challenges from depression to anxiety or
just needing a non-judgmental space to
voice our thoughts this year I've been
working out most days of the week to
keep my physical health strong and I
really do Champion therapy as a way to
strengthen my mental resilience and for
many better help is integral to that
process There's real value in better
helps accessible and adaptable service
they match you with a licensed therapist
and provide the option to switch if
necessary ensuring the right fit for
your mental health Journey as this year
winds down and we confront life's
complexities do consider betterhelp as a
resource really happy to be partner with
them this month so you can go to
betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off your
first month again that's BT R
hp.com sreal rejects so join us in
moving forward stronger together thank
you again all right reject Nation well
thank you again again to our sponsors
for this video that really does help
support the channel a lot if you go
ahead check them out let them know who
sent you by clicking the links and if
you're listening to spple spoy We just
watched Wonka the uh dark reboot of the
original Where it All Began Wonka begins
is what they call it gritty origin story
John please what did you think I enjoyed
this movie overall I would say quite
quite a good amount I thought this was
rather lovely was trepidacious a little
bit you know uh like the song yeah
absolutely a little trepidation going in
because obviously the legacy of the
books the legacy of the Gene Wilder
movie The Goat status of Johnny Depp uh
you know there's just a lot of baggage
going into something like this and it's
hard to capture true magic a second time
and while this might not be like you
know a classic in the same way um you
know this worked past a good amount of
any like you know preliminary cynicism
or skepticism I might have had like
there are ways in which at times yeah
like there are moments where you're like
oh like I can feel them reaching for the
weird but a good amount of time like I
thought they got to the weird and The
Whimsy and stuff like that like it could
be weirder in some aspects it could be
more Whimsical but I think we had a very
similar experience in that the more it
went on the more I was just kind of you
know swallowed up in its good nature and
its fun and its high Jinks and I mean
you know coming from having seen the two
Paddington movies I 100% understand why
they got Paul King to do this because
this does feel very Paddington esque in
terms of what the adventure is how it is
cast uh you know having these notable
actors you know show up to be these
bumbling villains and stuff like that
and the kind of you know uh sweet and
and compassionate wrap-ups that a lot of
things get um so yeah like not maybe
like a slam slam dunk but I came out of
or at least I'm sitting here now in the
Afterglow quite uh quite satisfied and
uh feeling rather you know uplifted and
light you know like in terms of of a
singing voice you know I feel like a lot
of people like Timothy sham I think does
a a fine job a nice job you know with
the songs uh and being that it's a movie
like I'm cool with that uh you know if
this was like Broadway I would have like
a greater set of Demands for what the
vocals have to be but uh but yeah for
what this is and for everybody that got
together in the Charisma of the cast I
quite enjoyed myself what did you think
sir I am of similar mind I suppose yeah
I heard I I heard that people like love
this movie before watching it I didn't
really hear much of the uh negativity
around like the not the negativity but
the mixed bag side of things I heard an
equal amount of though like I heard just
as many people say like I was surprised
how much I loved this and then other
people being like it's a cynical kind of
rehash it's a bunch of the same stuff
and you won't remember the music in a
day and a half you know it's like I
heard a good amount of
both I think as a family as a family
movie it is a really solid family movie
it's a really solid good time and I
think that it it sort of reminds me of
that time when Disney was doing like
liveaction sequels even though it's not
sequel It's a prequel um but liveaction
sequels to like the Mary Poppins movie
and the Christopher Robin definitely
where they're like greed is bad you
know that's like the message that's the
message of this movie in a lot of ways
too sure greed is bad you know and I I
love that message from any movie studio
with any of their movies especially a
studio like WB yeah with their recent
practices any big movie studio that
wants to tell me that I I love love
hearing it from them G is bad and I hope
this movie we made serious profit off of
it and paid people the minimum we needed
to pay them in order to get it done uh
but but the voice behind this one I
prefer over those movies like there
there was more I thought it was fun and
it grew on me as it went in the first
like 20 to 30 minutes I I did I was
questioning like am I really going to
enjoy this movie like and weirdly it
wasn't really the musical numbers or
anything of that nature it was more when
there was just scenes and there was this
heavy amount of instrumental music that
I thought was kind of in contradiction
with the editing and pacing uh and the D
like just the overall direction I
thought like the music was kind of the
instrumentals during scene work were
were were feeling forced to the point
where I was like the music is really
trying to tell me how to feel about this
but it's not quite lining up with the
way this movie is actually being edited
so it felt like in in contradiction with
itself and maybe it's just something
that like my brain would sub objectively
latch on to that your average movie
goinging audience would not really give
a [__] about but I gave a [__] about it
and uh as it went it was around the
musical number of the three bad guys the
chocolate cartel and keeg and Michael
Key when things started to Jive better
for me I started to really Vibe with the
film itself and and uh you know Willie
Wonka and the little girl now that whole
time
Nole yeah the it would Noodle and like
their chemistry I thought was really
good and it it wasn't like a wink at the
audience of hey Willy won an orphan even
though that's I'm sure what the
Inception was of that like pair him up
with an orphan you know and uh who
probably has greater keys to a bigger
fortune and so I I really I really like
their chemistry a lot and the fact that
they really made her more of the heart
like her story is more of the heart
again kind of doing a a Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory kind of story but
without doing a Charlie the Chocolate
Factory kind of story yeah and you know
the explor ation of London I thought was
fun although they made London feel kind
of small like it kind of like small
little like Town Square you know mhm you
know you spend time in like one Central
Area it feels like when you go to Harry
Potter land at Universal Studios like
it's not a real land it's like this is a
little little shopping CER in those few
scenes where they cut to that wide shot
of the coast you realize like oh that's
right we're in like a whole country here
whereas yeah we mostly spend time in the
wash house in like the you know Shopping
Square of the you know Grand Gourmet or
whatever that thing is called and then
the cathedral and then when they go to
the library at the end I was like oh oh
there are like other places around and I
had a I had difficulty getting on board
with uh Timothy shal's and like I
haven't seen too many Timothy shalam
movies like call me by your name Cen is
work on SNL and uh that count as a movie
I mean it's a performance and yeah
what's the other one Dune dude there's
definitely stuff I miss ladybird blah
blah blah I'm I haven't seen like a lot
of his other movies um and I'm not like
a Timothy shalam hater and I liked him
and everything I've seen him in then and
I've only seen I saw Charlie and
Chocolate Factory when it came out the
giant f one I saw it when it came out
don't really remember it um and I saw
Willie Wonka so much to the point that I
wasn't sure what the Beats were when I
when I watched it I really Lov that Wily
Wonka movie and and I knew I knew you
can't go in expecting that or or or
something of that kind and so I was
really I was I was really open-minded
going into this but there was something
about Timothy shalam in the beginning
that was really challenging for me where
I thought some of his teamw work was
really good but it was when he was kind
of going for like the bigger more
eccentric uh emotions when he kind of go
loud right I felt like he was trying to
hit notes I don't mean that in a singing
musical sense I just in a performative
sense he tried to hit notes and it it
felt like he was acting but I kind of
felt that way about the whole movie at
that that not the whole movie but like
by that point in the film within that
first half hour that the whole movie was
sort of acting that it was trying to be
you know uh we need to be weird so let's
just go like let's let's do weird things
but it it never like seemed like it was
coming from the heart yeah to do weird
wild and Whimsical I think you need to
embrace like a a spirit and a and like a
physical Rhythm of the movie that a
movie in this position doesn't have the
time to embody cuz you got to like kind
of luxuriate and let those things unfold
whereas this movie has to move and it's
like two hours long which it doesn't it
didn't really like drag or feel over
long to me but but at the same time yeah
it's got to keep things moving and it's
got to kind of move at A Clockwork I
think there is I think that's kind of
the essence of the Wonka aesthetic but
also the trickiness to nail is you have
to make move like clockwork but you also
have to like allow yourself to lean into
the weirdness and like let that guide
the pace and the tone sometimes and
there are times when I don't think they
could fully do that no and with Timothy
sham yeah it's like I I liked his
performance and I thought he was quite
Charming he like he he won me over with
his General Charisma and it's like I I I
thought he got stronger as he went it
was after it was literally like probably
after the half hour mark where I was
like oh I'm I I am on board for this guy
yeah and I kept getting this feeling of
like you know oh okay this this is I
almost felt like I was watching like
some Broadway show where it's like
you're seeing a different cast and like
oh this guy's stepping into the lead
role now how's he do and and and I
thought that it's it's yeah it's that
odd thing of I don't fully get the
complete range of that you
know whoever you want to compare to but
you know just like that General like
this guy's kooky and Whimsy like that
definitely took a while to build up for
me and I think there were times where it
did achieve AI that his performance did
achieve that but it's uh not like I
don't know when you're watching not to
I'm not going to hold him up to Gene
Wilder too much because a lot here
worked for me and I and he Charmed me
certainly uh but but yeah it's like
there's a when you're watching Gene
Wilder there's like a magic where you're
like this guy just like is this guy
versus like yeah I'm watching Timothy
shamay jump into a role that's a little
broader than I'm used to seeing him and
that's fun and I like the moments where
he achieves it but he's not always like
I'm like oh man this unlocked like a
whole new realm of his talent that I
can't wait to see more like you know I
would I'd be happy for him to take weird
more weird roles but it wasn't like the
revelation of like oh man he had all
this craziness inside of him you know
yeah well I mean the Wily wonk at that
point in that movie is is he a seasoned
willly Wonka he's also a lot more uh a
lot more destitute to the guy he's he's
he's isolated yeah like no one's like
seen or heard from him in years you know
is is and there's more of a mysterious
Allure and he doesn't come into the film
till way later so the direction and
approach to storytelling for that story
of Willie Wonka lends itself to a
different type of perspective the
audience will have of him you know and
more to play into where he like we're
starting this off with willly wono we
got to make him more relatable we got to
make him a little bit more leading man
classic in a way and a little bit more
safe I think this movie plays is safe
it's a really safe film and like I said
it's like a family film it's fun there's
musical numb yeah I'm probably not
really going to remember but when
they're when they're playing out I think
it's enjoyable I think the musical
numbers are very enjoyable I think the
Keegan Michael Key bit of him getting
fatter is really funny actually and I
think the whole Supporting Cast is
really strong uh Lush production designs
uh throughout very much um like you
could feel like the Aesthetics to this
they had a lot of fun piecing all this
together and overall it is an enjoyable
uh
experience and I I wouldn't quite
categorize it as like a very moving film
for me other than it always had a fun
entertainment enjoyable time it's very
sweet yeah no it's like a sweet family
film but but yet um you know the only
thing I would say as I'm trying to like
not compare it because I I know what
that door open opens up because then it
automatically makes people think that
all I was doing was comparing it when I
really didn't even have the other movie
on my mind the entire time no it just
it's like that's just the easiest thing
to kind of use as an example of how they
made it work because they're trying to
ultimately achieve similar emotional
responses that the
original I would say I don't I haven't
read the books so the original movie at
least was trying to have you achieve
achieve so sometimes my brain when
talking about it might go to what that
original film did that I thought they
succeeded at where they didn't and
here's where the breaking Nexus point
for me I think really is is that as much
production design went into this as
great as the costumes
were I felt like this was artificial the
whole time whereas I thought like
captured there even though the other one
is really
Fantastical I believed it it was
tangible it's an older film so it's like
much older and they had to build so much
yeah whereas here I I I did it's not
like disingenuous like the movie's heart
is in the right place the whole time I
think and it's intent and motives I
think are all in the right place um and
like I I I would not call this movie
be insincere I wouldn't say that I would
say that its effort is more at the
Forefront than it's than uh it's ex
where they wanted to to land you know
like you could feel kind of them trying
and the other one uh I I was I thought
what like weirdly didn't feel like
artificial to me at all like it didn't
feel fake to me I'm not talking just
that the chocolate like the world of it
felt real from the first half with this
world that like is like who's Willy
Wonka and the London that it inhabits
all that felt as as Fantastical as it is
and as weird as it is when they're like
all these people are sleeping in the bed
like look how freaking poor we are you
know the I it was tangible and to me I
didn't feel that it was tangible I was
aware that it was a uh I could see all
that they were doing you know yeah you
can see the the Big Shiny Hollywood
production nness and the Beats we got to
move to to keep this on you know test
audience quota to boil it down it
weirdly did not feel lived in despite
all of its efforts to achieve that and
that was the barrier that it held for me
to truly feel connected to it in spite
of the fact that I know that I had a
really fun time watching it and that I
could appreciate everything that was
here yeah uh there was an element where
I did not
fully it's like going on a
date and you're like you're a really
nice person and I really I really like
you and we could be friends but I don't
think we have the chemistry you know
that's how I felt with this movie
was like I had a really nice time
getting to know you but I don't think
we're going to see each other again yeah
yeah I enjoyed my time here this was
very pleasant but I'm not moved in the
way I would like to be I I don't feel
the Sparks yeah yeah and I can sort of
see that because like beyond the vibe
because you know like Ral doll isn't
necessarily and I think the the original
Gene Wilder movie certainly encompasses
this the Johnny Depp one very much leans
into the fact that you know uh what I've
what I've heard if I can just try to
make a quick assessment what what I've
heard sorry to P you off is that um the
Tim Burton one is more faithful outside
of
Johnny yeah yeah yeah yeah whereas uh
and I feel like Jean Wilder was probably
closer to how Wonka in in at least my
recollection of the book because he does
have this I hear it's dark and weird and
twisted Ral doll's writing is Ry and
twisted and and you know heartfelt at
times and fun at times and Whimsical in
its own way so like this certainly
encompasses some of that but I I would
agree and I think that's the Troublesome
thing about about like a Mary Poppins 2
or coming back to something like this is
that you know you have to aim for
greatness even if you're not being as
presumptuous as to assume that you will
achieve it and so yeah if you look at
that original Wonka movie you have just
a more palpable sense of like it'll it
tugs your heartstrings at times and then
when you get the real catharsis by the
end you know like it is cathartic and
there is like heart swell there and the
stuff that's twisted like is actually
pretty twisted and that whole like
tunnel scene is kind of scary and weird
and so yeah it's like the movie this
movie I feel like flirts with all those
tones to some degree or another doesn't
really ever go to an extent that's fully
kind of down one of those rabbit holes
perhaps suffice or save like the
more heartfelt elements but I I guess I
would agree is like despite the fact
that they have all the means to do the
craziest most imaginative stuff with
this I I I think that the movie Magic is
a bit muddled in the fact that yeah
there's certain things you can only do
with CGI but a lot of the stuff that
they're trying to do here you could do
with sets with real chocolate if they
wanted to and so I feel like there is an
element of movie Magic that that first
film has that they might have done
better to incorporate a bit more of here
because it is a story about believing in
Magic partly and you know there are
already like Whimsical chocolates that
do slightly more directly magical things
than are presented in the in my
recollection of the original story than
are presented in the movie you get that
one bit where they're like flying up and
they have to burp their way down but
even that in that movie feels
a bit more grounded than it does here
and so yeah I feel like that doesn't
hurt because again there's great design
work but knowing that it's all
CG it just kind of yeah there's
something that doesn't click as you know
uh canell about the movie Magic of that
uh and then yeah and then beyond because
I'm because I think the thing is that
I'm sure there's a lot in here that
actually was practical sure and I'm sure
there was a lot in like I'm sure they
built a lot of cool sets and stuff that
when you watch watching behind the
scenes and I think some of that
appreciation for it or the again I keep
coming back to the word connection or
the connection to those elements uh gets
lost in other things that are not real
so you know it's like that thing where
like Five Nights at Freddy's they're
like we built all these except you can't
quite tell because there's a whole lot
of other CGI that makes it all just kind
of c and so yeah you have you have that
quality and I don't know exactly what
would bridge the gap there cuz like
again like this is a movie filled with
things filled with good work and and
filled with things that do work for what
they are intending to do it just yeah
it's like there's just an excess layer
of Magic on top of that that feels like
it could have been a little better
served by something like this and I mean
I feel like it's conscientious for the
most part in terms of what they decided
to do with the story and how they build
this Ensemble and how they borrow things
from the original story and for uh from
other sort of Ral doll esque Works uh
you know to to amalgamate all of this
but at the same time yeah it's like I
don't really feel
like for a movie it's the tricky thing
is like you don't want to give too much
of a backstory to your character such as
this because obviously they need to
maintain some level of Mystique or
whatever uh but at the same time I feel
like we could have gotten I don't know
maybe like a little more personal with
Willie in some way shape or form I liked
all the stuff with his mom um but you
know like once we're moving there's so
many parts and stuff like that there's
just so much happening and I think about
like I liked again I liked the
experience of watching this quite a bit
but I would still probably in the Paul
King catalog rank it below the other two
Paddington because again while he is
kind of the perfect director as based
off of those as business cards those
movies I think do clinch a little bit
more of that magic and a little bit more
of that heart swell uh that you want
maybe from something like this because
this has all like the the madness and
the fun of seeing this wide cast there a
whole bunch of great comedic actors and
dramatic actors you know playing big
characters on display and so like yeah I
can't fa this movie for effort
whatsoever but it is yeah it is just
like that little extra true sense of
wildness and true sense of we brought
magic to life yeah and I think they
shied away from the depth of willly
Wonka uh the as the character sure and
like there's a lot of Latter latitude to
play with there because he is kind of
like the doctor in a way he is like you
know he can be Mercurial he can be very
Whimsical and dreamy and then he can be
you know Twisted send kids off to their
death well I think they were constantly
uh on the verge of really going more to
the and that that usually I mean can
come in the form of how uh I'm not
talking like uh you know see more of his
back story it's more watching how he
reacts to certain scenes you know yeah
yeah seeing his come out through him
feigning rage towards Charlie in the
first movie you know is or there's also
like a bit of a while he's like joyful
there's also like a sadness to him you
know what I mean like he's multi he
feels like multifaceted yeah and here I
felt like Timothy shalam was a little
more and maybe this the writing in
Direction was a little more focused on
you know the the the quirkiness with you
know uh being a little little sad about
some stuff sure yeah but again it's like
none of those flavors go as Vivid as
they could yeah so that's what I mean by
how I think they played it a little more
safe CU they have more to gamble with
here the times we live in now how they
make movies yeah now this is a
blockbuster property yeah that we got a
franchises you know tot there's there's
there's elements there that I'm also
aware of that I'm like do I really fault
the movie or was it some at the end of
the day it is a war ver so maybe there's
some studio shits that I don't know
about or maybe this is the the picture
that that they wanted to tell uh
wholeheartedly uh either way you know at
the end of the day they wanted to just
make uh an acceptable family film
everyone could go enjoy and hear some
tunes and and appreciate the candy while
it's on display uh but for for my taste
uh yeah no I I'm very much like I
enjoyed it uh but I probably don't
really care to revisit it at the same
time anytime soon at least and I
probably imagine I'm not really going to
think about this movie honestly yeah so
that's again that's just my opinion uh
but I I like I overall like liked it but
moving on to a different person sure I
feel weird cuz it's like for me I'm like
I like this more than I thought I would
I don't love it though it's the same
thing it's like I would be happy to
watch this again and it's like a movie
that would be like oh hey like take this
home to the family or something like
that uh because again there were ways in
which it surprised me with how much it
pulled me in or made me enjoy it but
yeah like it's still kind of burdened
with having to play as widely as it has
to play and be the kind of caliber film
making movie that it has to be panned
out for them it did pan out for them and
I mean like again this could have gone
much wor the only thing that that I I
think the Oompa Loompa bit was a little
funny to me because like in the
advertising I would thought that like
Hugh Grant would be like a a very
featured player but he's kind of got
those two scenes or two or three scenes
and he kind of exists as like a he he's
presented as I mean OAS are like the
most Whimsical part almost or or among
the more Whimsical parts and he's mostly
like a plot
mechanic plus you know a couple fun
little bits uh I can feel some of the
course correction they wanted to do sure
problematic sides of the Oompa
loomas them right you know you can feel
some of that yeah no it was a wanting to
be here yeah he was exiled by his own
people and then they went into business
together he didn't just kidnap them and
bring here he didn't just go rip them
from their Homeland a really smart
capable guy yeah he was just a good
businessman and he probably attracted
the other palas with opportunity and if
he kind of becomes really Wonka's best
friend in the year yeah yeah this is
completely unpr problematic but Hugh
Grant has that thing you know where I
see him in interviews and he kind of
seems like an [__] but I see him in
movies and he's that charm works on me
so does even talking about working on
this it seemed like it was a real
cantankerous experience for the guy you
know but watching him here uh I think
you I I actually weirdly I enjoyed him I
I it's that Hugh Grant charm I enjoyed
him quite a lot he's playing Hugh Grant
as an nooma Loompa God oh watch
Paddington is exactly that watch
Paddington 2 I mean I haven't seen any
of this Panton movie so uh I I like him
here and I think he very
fun H but uh yeah I got I got really no
problems with other than sometimes look
[__] weird but sometimes his mouth
movements look real real funky but it
could have looked way worse but it could
have looked way worse all of this could
have been a train wreck and uh and like
everything is pretty good it's like it
could have been a noisy mess yeah yeah
like everything is at least pretty good
and I feel like like even just timoth
Timothy shalam at the lead is sort of
like a good metaphor for everything
because part of you is like yeah this
really looks the part and it's it's kind
of getting there and it's really
throwing itself into this I don't know
if it's necessarily like really got the
pipes you know for it or is really like
pulling the full range of all the colors
but you know pretty good pretty solid
you know yeah yeah like I could I become
much more aware especially since Sweeney
Todd and and being in the camp when that
came out I was like I like Johnny Depp's
singing performance and like here I feel
like it's it's a bit less distracting
but it is also too like I like that they
threw down for song and dance and stuff
like that and I thought his vocal
performance was solid but it is that
thing of like okay like I could imagine
what this would sound like with someone
who can like really nail these songs
well the difference with Sweeney Todd is
Sweeney Todd CD the character that Demon
Barber yes of Fleet Street yes he has a
lot of emotional depth so when he is
seen he while not a a singer that lives
up to the theater he is able to still
bring the emotion yes and that saves a
lot of the song and experience and hence
why a lot of people are still singing
the songs when Johnny D came out and did
it you
sir because there's an emotion there
whereas the especially the new songs
here they're not really written for
emotional thrust they're written for a
sound they're written for a soundtrack
yeah they're written for the tone and
flavor this scene needs right now yeah
yeah cuz it's like double the musical
numbers than like the original movie too
like like it's like not it's like a it's
a full-blown musical you know a certain
point I was like oh it's like every
other scene of musical but then it stops
uh and then they start reserving that
but it was a point where I was like I
guess this is like a Non-Stop musical
whereas the other one is not that you
know yeah totally um and and uh and so
that's why I
think like I weirdly feel like Timothy
Shamy might actually be a better singer
than Johnny Depp yeah but the
performance of the singing doesn't
register as strong or make as much of an
impact because the songs given to him
don't require as much of that emotion to
be in there to carry as like a dialogue
or a scene you know so it leaves that
gap of like oh then an amazing voice
could fill some of this in whereas he's
doing like a fine it's one of those
where I don't want to be like oh he
sucked he did a fine job that fine
especially for someone like me who's not
as ATT tuned to catching the ear and the
notes yeah my ears I don't have I'm not
not a good I can't sing and um so when I
hear this I'm like oh yeah for my ears
he's carrying the T for he's good he's
good he's really good but for someone
who like really sings I'm sure
[__] i' got to that point in my life
where I can hear or like I can for me
I'm like no that's good to me but I can
also imagine there's theater people
people who actually really commit their
time to singing we're like oh oh man
that that could have been a lot better
you know it's the power it's like he can
carry the tune like there's certainly
autot tune employed this didn't feel
like one of the more AO like you know
you listen to a lot lot of the Disney
stuff now and is heavily autotuned which
is a whole other conversation that
drives me nuts this felt a bit more
natural and it certainly yeah it's like
I appreciated that I could get the sense
for his voice and mostly it's just about
like having a little bit of that extra
power where it counts you know that
extra flourish of vibr or whatever it is
yeah Express
expressivity
expressionism expresso espresso Wonka
chocolates
yeah probably be on the last point this
did not make like I was watching that
other Wonka movie and I was like God
damn I need some like the whole time oh
that opening credit scene alone where
they're just showing like layers of
chocolate being poured over like Wafers
and [__] yeah but this one I know make
Chate kind of a turn off yeah you watch
Charlie in the in the OG one bite into
that Whipples scrumptious and you're
like oh my God I need one and in this
one you're like I don't know
like they don't especially there's a lot
of like fake chocolate that look gross I
don't begrudge them to designs here
chocolate rivers and [__] looks so gross
here like that looks gross you know sure
I I don't begrudge them to the designs
but it is a funny Motif to me throughout
the movie where you do have these
chocolates that just don't look like
chocolates whatsoever so and then
they're flying around and and all that
[__] so like it's and also the people's
response to the magic of the chocolates
I think actually weirdly takes away the
magic you need need the ju to position
you need the scary side of the magic
beyond the scary side like when people
are flying at first it's just like oo
cool yeah you know uh as opposed to like
what is this wonder of the world you
know like and the cup busts in and he's
like oh just a couple people flying
around and I'm like this is a place that
has a daydreaming tax which is a
Whimsical flourish that makes sense to
me and then them rushing in and being
like this is totally normal is not a
Whimsical flourish that makes sense to
me and that to me was kind of a telling
point of the magic might not feel like
magic there needs to be contrast you
need to yeah exactly that's my point you
need you need the contrast yeah you need
to have some kind of like they only
especially when you go to the firsto
like the story I imagine of the first L
Wonka you know like all I do is like buy
chocolate and eat it there's this like
magical [__] they're selling on the
shelves yeah yeah yeah it's like the and
and the stuff that is like sort of
magical or sci-fi is like is grounded
enough it's like the Everlasting
Gobstopper that you can can suck forever
and it never goes away that's fine it's
a Sci-Fi thing but it's not literally
flying like a flying piece of chocolate
well I mean even without that movie even
without the original story I I would I
would still have the same like well
here's what works against the magic is
the fact of the people are not it's like
in a horror movie you know you need your
main characters to be scared otherwise
we're not going to be scared yeah same
likewise here if the world is not
responding to It Like It's Magic that
they're witnessing for the first time
then no then I'm not going to feel like
I'm watching magic well that's that's
what also got me confused when they had
the whole Yeti tears thing and they like
spiked the batch of chocolates cuz I was
like okay so are these just I mean I get
that they exist on the planet in this
universe but I'm like I thought kind of
the whole Allure of wily Wonka was that
he brings with him these sort of magical
Whimsical flourishes not that just
anybody has yey tears around that they
could spite like why don't you all have
crazy sci-fi chocolates why are the of
your chocolate's just normal
chocolates you know that don't have
Magic Properties yeah so yeah to have
like some kind of Panic or whatever like
that whole scene is treated like a joke
and it's a call back because they're
doing the whole thing of like oh instead
of burp you got a fart to get down and
and and all that kind of gets smeared in
just like ah you know it's it's a fun
wacky thing where it should be like
these three guys you could add that
motivation to the three chocolateers of
the chocolate cartel by having them be a
little bit like what is this you know
alchemy that this guy not only is he
threatening our business but also like
what was this we just you know witnessed
and and were you know literally affected
by I don't know but guys what did you
guys think I give it
a
gen
6.9 out of 10 oh okay sure I'll give it
like a
7.3 it's weird I feel like
intellectually we feel the same way and
and maybe I don't know well the more we
talked about it though it went down okay
I was more like a seven and a half and
we talked about it and I was like that's
little L for me sure sure sure that's
six I was think s and half like a
99,000 SC somewhere between seven and a
seven and a half years we're an
unpopular opinion even though we we Tech
we liked it squarely in the middle of
the we didn't like it enough yeah we we
don't accept this as the new definitive
Wonka enough we're just being contr
on purpose that's right contr we love
dealing with
that and then being characterized as
people who only ever think that
particular way yeah we love it we love
it so much um anyway leave your thoughts
Down Below on
Wonka uh subscribe click that Bell and
let's patron of the day shout out this
bad
boy Adelia Chamberlain
Adelia we are going to change the lyrics
of De is gone oh no to and I don't
actually know what this is about oh good
I've definitely heard the song before
it's by Johnny Cash yes and we're going
to discover together but instead of deia
I'm going to change to ailia see what we
did here we go okay
Adelia oh
Adelia Adelia all my life if I hadn't
shot for Adelia yes I'd have had her for
my wife oh no a is gone one more round a
de is gone he's shot more than once I
went up to Memphis or Nebraska wherever
you're from defin breath and I met a
deia there found her in her parlor and
tied her to her chair excellent a is
gone for one more round a is gone what
is happening in this song how how many
times does he shoot her she was low down
and trifling and she was cold and mean
kind of evil make me want to grab my
Submachine what a is gone he's going to
hit you with the chopper adilia runia is
gone first time I shot her I shot her in
the side what is this hard to watch her
suffer but with a second shot she died
it's about your evil twin ad is gone one
more round a is gone pour one out but
jayer oh
jayer jayer I can't sleep you get your
come upins now cuz all the around my
bedside I heard the patter of adelia's
feet haunting him in the afterlife
adelia's gone one more round the de is
gone a throw one back so if your woman's
devilish you can let her run or you can
bring her down and
do my God John Go Johnny Go Go Johnny a
is gone one more round a is
gone is gone one more round a is gone
now at your funeral I'm going to sing
that in honor of you and confuse the
hell of your entire family I've never
heard this song before and I think this
is perfect I always thought it was about
a horse until I read the lyrics it could
be a bad horse yeah yeah yeah it's like
a devilish think that is devilish brood
Mar or something like that but you know
clearly this was inspired by like the
the opposite traits of you anyway I hope
you're doing well ad and I hope you
recover from all the gunshot yes we love
you stay safe out
[Music]
there